ça me touche encore beaucoup et je me
sens encore vachement coupable donc je
veux pas trop en parler ça la justice
fera sa lumière aussi vous sentez
coupable Julie parce que j'y suis
retournée et c'est et c'est ça que les
gens arrivent pas à comprendre c'est ça
s'appelle l'emprise ça c'est ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'emprise euh chaque hiver des crèches
de Noël sont installées dans des hôtels
de ville malgré la loi de séparation de
l'Église et de l'État c'est notamment le
cas à bziier euh qui est chaque année
retoqué et qui va une nouvelle fois
inaugurer sa crèche dans une semaine
pour Noël 2023 on vous a préparé un Réap
doit-on pouvoir installer des crèches de
Noël dans les mairies oui non vous
répondez également chez vous les chéris
merci
[Musique]
regardez ce weekend la commune de Bézier
s'apprête à inaugurer sa traditionnelle
crèche de Noël au sein de l'Hôtel de
Ville une crèche qui crée depuis
plusieurs ur années la polémique jugé
contraire au principe de laïcité des
institutions de la République et non
conforme à la loi de 1905 sur la
séparation de l'Église et de l'État le
tribunal administratif de Montpellier
avait notamment sommé l'année dernière
Robert Menard de la retirer on obéit
mais je regrette cette mesure qui est
d'une grande brutalité face à quelque
chose qui pourtant rassemble et cette
année à quelques jours de son
inauguration une plainte contre la
mairie de béziier aurait désormais été
déposé pour protester contre cette
crèche alors doit-on pouvoir installer
des crèches de Noël dans les
mairies alors qui dit non alors non je
dis non alors je sais très bien que la
loi PEP entendu aujourd'hui non je sais
que la loi peut être contournée on t pas
beaucoupend je sais très bien que
parfois les tribunaux administratifs de
pas beaucoup entendu de raison au merire
mais pour moi ça ne se discute pas les
crèches de Noël avec la Nativité que je
respecte énormément n'ont rien à faire
dans un établissement public si on cède
là-dessus alors à ce moment-là on cède
surtout donc laïicité dans les mairie
comme la loi le prévoit et pas pas du
tout d'exonération de responsabilité des
Maes qui tentent de contourner la loi on
est au-delà de la religion c'est un fait
culturel c'est puis j'en ai marre on est
dans un pays
judéo-chrétien alors à ce moment-là on
ne fait plus du tout Noël on ne prononce
plus le nom tu rends ta prime tu rends
ta prime de Noël et puis on prend plus
les primes de Noël on ne fait plus Noël
je suis désolé ça va ça va au-delà c'est
de la culture il y a des milliers de
gens qui viennent juste pour voir pour
c'est joli et c'est pas mais quelqu'un
voudrait lire un extrait de la Bible
dans la mairie je dirais non là ça n'
bah voilà mais là ça n'a rien à voir
donc moi je n'en peux plus qu'on est à
se battre maintenant pour fêter Noël en
France excusez-moi elle a raison mais je
un truc que je comprends pas Noël ça
existe depuis la nuit des temps on a
tous grandi avec Noël avec les sapins
les crèches les guirlandes et là tout
d'un coup on vient nous sortir que Noël
est problématique que Noël est
problématique que Noël est trop
religieux alors qu'il y a plein de gens
comme l'a dit Daniel pour qui Noël en
réalité même si Noël prend ses sources
dans la religion Noël n'est pas
religieux pour plein de gens c'est c'est
juste le mot Noël c'est une ambiance
c'est un sapin c'est effectivement des
crèches et je trouve ça malsin et
dangereux dans cette période où les
religions dans dans leur caractère
extrémiste peuvent poser problème de
créer des embroules là où il y en a pas
laisser les gens fêter Noël tranquille
laisser les
crèches je le voulais
celui-là mais j'ai rien jouur de padle
vous êtes
nul c'est pour le c'était un
avertissement ga il a un autre non c'est
un avertissement euh Raymond moi moi je
suis sur leur ligne de conduite ça
dérange qui en fait Noël qui ça dérange
qui de voir des sapins c'est joli il y a
une crèche tu vas en mairie tu vas pas
en mairie pour prendre en photo avec
c'est quoi c'est une crèche c'est quoi
c'est une crèche ex c'est depuis depuis
10 15 ans qu'on veut interdire Noël les
mères qui mettent plus de sapin dans
leur ville faut plus de crèche dans les
villes c'est un pays de chrétien Noël
c'est pas grave c'est une fête c'est pas
grave et pendant 10 15 jours il y a un
no il y a des sapins il y a des crèches
ça dérange pas c'est joli l'espr
là je comprends g c'est sur le principe
de la laïcité qui est inextinguible
effectivement dans dans les textes de
loi les M qui le font sont depuis qu
Vale c'est depuis quand ça c'est depuis
qu le texte de loi moi j'ai regarde non
moi j'ai
regard pas 1950 c'est depuis 2016 il a
commencé à avoir le bordel au Conseil
constitutionnel ils ont fait une loi
2016 Guillaume l'a dit c'est depuis bien
avant pourquoi
depuis6 m mais depuis pourquoi c'est
seulement maintenant commence à enever
les sapins et qu'on commence à dire non
on veut plus voir Noël les mec ils ont
jamais été des enfants ces gensl c'est
super bien Noël laissz Noël tranquille
voulez pas fêter Noël on vous force pas
pour revenir à ce que pour revenir à ce
que dis Raymon qui s'est plain de Noël
en fait se PL vous av entendu un
musulman un juif un catholique n'importe
qui dire Noël c'est nul on veut pas de
Noë on veut pas de Noë dans les rues on
veut pas de sapin de Noël je veux dire
on connait plein de communautés même qui
fê no
et just pour une qu'igion qui réie de
diref un fait d'une religion qui réunit
moi je trouve ça cool et et c'est pas
parce que il y en a plusieurs qui vont
cracher sur d'autres religions et qui
vont dire et ben non en fait venez on se
réunit même pour d'autres religions et
ça c'est cool à momenté faut arrêter de
cracher sur ce qui est positif venant
d'une religion regardez on est sur un
plateau de Noël on est dans une émission
avec des personnes de toute confession n
pas une émission catholique pour autant
c'est
ridicule non mais oui mais
c Géraldine alors moi c'est vrai que
quand j'étais jeune il y avait des
crèches dans les mairies et ça ne posait
absolument aucun problème il y avait pas
de polémique il y avait pas de on était
pas on se sentait pas stigmatisé il y
avait pas de revendication il y avait
pas de problème il y avait pas de
problème bon aujourd'hui je pense que
c'est un problème et moi je suis pour la
laïcité donc je ne veux pas qu'il y ait
de signentatoire de religion dans
l'espace public je le veux pour toutes
les religion donc oui là là je fais un
pas de côté et je me soumets et je me
dis ok on dégage les crèches des mairies
on les met dans les églises c'est très
bien comme ça avec le petit Jésus avec
les rois tout ça oui on pourrait les
mettre sur le parv à ce moment-l ce
moment dans un espace public pourquoi
pas mais je ne veux pas que ce soit dans
un espace qui qui dépend de l'état voilà
je ne veux pas je je ne veux pas que ce
soit dans dans les écoles je ne veux pas
dans les écoles publiques je veux pas
que ce soit dans les mairies je veux pas
que ce soit dans les département c'est
très bien comme ça parce qu's par
qu'près il y aura des revendication en
d'ailleurs Galine certaines m s'amus
fous en fait non je m'en fous pas des
revendications c'estàd que ah B alors si
on fait la crèche alors pourquoi on fait
pas ça non en fait non mais peu importe
je ne veux qu'il y ait aucune
revendication aucune
religion parce on fait pas ça parce
qu'on le fait depuis 1900 on le fait
depuis des années donc on changera pas
quelque chose d'un pays comme a dit
Daniel d'un pays chrétien on changera
pas on restera avec not tradition moi
j'ai pas envie de me soumettre sur une
histoire de tradition je rentre même pas
dans l'histoire de religion que chacun
fait ses fêtes
tranquillement certaines jou avec la loi
d'ailleurs parce qu' elles font leur
crèche à la fois dans la mairie et un
peu à l'extérieur de la mairie parce
qu'elles ont elles ont des des courettes
des choses comme ça et là effectivement
là elle ne tombent plus sur le coup de
la loi parce qu' elle joue sur le sur
l'ambigué du du
texte fais ta
vie moi moi j'ai envie de garder ma
France telle que je l'ai connu quand
j'allais à la mairie je voyais les
crèches quand j'allais dans un super
March à l'époque il y avait même une
crèche devant avec le Père Noël avec qui
on faisait une photo moi je trouve qu'il
y a rien de religieux évidemment ça fait
partie de la décoration ustrationésus
quand même qui
25 la tradition c'est pas une
signification religieuse particulière
les fêtes de fin d'année on aime grandir
avec le sapin avec les cadeaux le kiff
bon voilà quoi c'est tout mais le sapin
c'est pas religieux je suis d'accord
c'est paen on l'a dit l'autre jour le
père Noël comme comme est déguisé Cyril
voilà c'est effectivement ça n'est pas
religieux en revanche une crèche malgré
tout avec les rois mages avec Gabriel
avec le Jésus qui n à le 25 au matin là
enfin à min oui là c'est quand même
géraline tu c'est toi-même qui a dit que
ça te POS ça ne posait aucun problème à
personne il y a quelques années ça dit
quand même quelque chose de notre
société et moi ça m'inquiète et je n'ai
pas envie de C par du coup'que à la
franceav vous parlez de la loi mais la
loi le Conseil d'État s'est prononcé en
2016 et a expliqué que il y avait une
spécificité concernant c'est cette
demande parfois mais non elle est
systématique en fait parf non je te lis
le texte le caractère culturel
artistique et ou festif s'il est
démontré voilà s'il est démontré parfois
est démontré systématiquement il est
démontré systématiquement que il s'agit
de Noël à chaque fois évidemment que
dans chacune des mairies va être
démontré le caractère festif de
Noël justement tarrêtes pas juste à jés
tu t'arrêtes à ce que ça projette ça
chaque maie à mon avis pass pass entre
les entre les les gouttes parce
qu'effectivement il suffit simplement
d'expliquer au Conseil d'État que par
exemple le l'installation d'une crèche
dans la mairie fait venir x
visiteurs et voilà et puis donc il y a
en vrai pas pas de pas de réel sujet
parce que si elle est maline la mairie
elle peut pas ça fait 10 minutes qu'on
parle vous dites il y a pas de réel
sujet elle est quand même extraordinaire
on dit que on dit que tu t'es trompé que
la loi à laquelle tu fais référence elle
a été modifié par le Conseil d'État
d'une certaine façon puisqu'ils ont déjà
dit en 2016 qu'il pouvait y avoir un
caractère festif
quand quand il un usage local qui fait
que et tu sais que en fait tout ça vient
de la Ligue des droits de l'homme qui à
chaque fois dépose plainte mairie après
mairie parce qu'il s'agit de mairie soit
de droite soit d'extrême droite ou en
tous les cas classé comme T et et donc
ils vont faire de la politique là-dessus
mais ça n'a pas de sens mais ils ont
droit de déposer plainte
parfois
qui Fa ça qui fait ça donnez-m est-ce
que ça vous a intéressé tout ce qu'on a
dit pas du tout mais pas du tout mais
vraiment pas du tout qui n'a pas parlé
qui a quelque chose à dire d'intéressant
personne merci comme d'habitude on va
voir le sondage oui 92% ah ou toon moi
je suis d'accord oui franchement dérange
à non maisaline pas par parce qu'elle
voul te faire plaisir une fois dans la
semaine c'est très bien moi je suis pour
je suis pour à fond F culturell
sin je suis désolé je suis pour à fond
après il G verdz qui voilà qui comme
d'habitude voilà tout qui sacage tout
qui sacage le monde non mais c'est vrai
qu'est-ce qui te
dérange arrête avec la
lote arrte a
lo la morale aussi
pour est-ce que tu vois pas est-ce que
tu vois pas qu'en ce moment les gens il
se divisent à cause de la religion donc
pour une fois que les gensent réunir et
on devrait le faire avec toutes les
religions à chaque fois qu'il y a une
fête ou ch de positif et ben on le fait
tous ensemble c'est tout donc là on fait
Noël ensemble on mangera ensemble après
Ramadan et on fera qui pour ensemble tu
es pas content tu veux la guerre non
mais c'est bon calmez-vous là je suis
avec mon
pote des cadeau calmezvous je su avec
mon pote descend deux étages là direct
viens frérot on se barre on se barre
d'ici il aime pas Noël
viensard
on bar d'ici il aiment pas Noël j'
aaiment pas Noël on se barre
d'ici je t'ai grand je t'ai connu plus
grand
toi c'est y qu an le Père Noël euh ouais
alors non mais moi j'ai strictement rien
du tout contre la religion catholique
c'est
parfait un chien Gal mais pas oui si
vous voulez mais mais mais dans le débat
je ne comprends pas cette image elle est
très belle mais derrière vous mais elle
n'a rien à faire dans une mairie qui est
un é
que associations comme la liueo de
l'homme qui sont d'ailleurs en partie
financé par l'argent public pu s'agacer
de ce genre de chose c'est franchement
pas je je c'est perd son temps sont des
gens qui ont plein
de raison mais ils ont plein de fois
raison ils ont plein de combats à mener
notamment sur des gens qui sont
emprisonnés à travers le monde mais
franchement venir s'énerver sur
l'organisation de crèch dans des mairies
dans le sud de la France fr ça n'a aucun
intérêt c'est politique là c'est
juste
faire et puis arrête de jouer sur les
textes de loi pour pour ner une réalité
qui est que Noël est la fête la plus
populaire en France c'est une réalité
tout le monde même ceux qui ne sont pas
catholiques fêes Noël il y en a plein
qui F Noël ça fait plaisir à tout le
monde et toi tu veux les faire
ch mais pour autant les excuse-moi mais
pour autant les les non catholiques
lunettes pour autant juste je je peux
continuer ou on ch le
débat non mais pour autant les non
catholiques qui a a FAM tout ne m pas
crèche chez eu est-ce que tu mets une
crèche chez toi est-ce que tu mets une
crèche chez toi est-ce que vous mettez
une crèche chez vous CR vous mettez une
crèche chez vous avec le petit Jésus
tout Jésus c'est un gros coup alors le
petit José
j tout le monde le petit Jésus le petit
José il a petit you il a tout le monde
tout je pense que la crèche fait partie
du patrimoine de Noël
la meilleure preuve Guillaume c'est que
Yass Arafat il allait tous les ans à
Bethléem en Noël donc ça n'a rien à voir
avec la religion VO il y a des crèch
dans les synagogues et dans les mosquées
pardon il y a des crèches dans les
synagogues et les mosquées non non on
estexliquer que Nol ça
dépasse une célébration qui est plus
large que ça et ça n'a jamais été un
problème jusqu'à ce qu'il y ait
quelques les gars on va se retrouver
dans un
[Musique]
instant merci Julie d'être avec nous à
visage découvert cette fois-ci pour no
té lespectateurs c'est la première fois
que tu part à visage découvert c'est la
première fois oui c'est fou oui voilà
donc c'est vrai que la dernière fois tu
avais choisi de garder l'anonymat
pourquoi tu tu as pas ravisage découvert
aujourd'hui tiens parce que je me suis
beaucoup fait attaquer sur les résseau
c'est vrai qu'il y a les photos qu'on
circulai sur moi et finalement à
visageer découvert je trouve que le
témoignage aussi il parle plus qu'à
visage couvert c'est c'est sûr c'est
sûr on va rappeler l'affaire juste
qu'est-ce que tu qu'est-ce que tu
réponds à à
l'avocat j'ai pas forcément quelque
chose à répondre à l'avocat je trouve
juste je trouve juste l'accusation
ignoble
ignoble parce que tentative d'extorsion
de fond j'ai jamais demandé un centime
donc c'est c'est vraiment ignoble je
comprends pas du tout même euh Julie on
va revenir sur ton histoire et tu vas
nous dire pourquoi voilà aujourd'hui il
y a cette tripost juste Myriam Palomba
on en est où de cette affaire alors on
en est c'est assez c'est assez troublant
parce que donc hier deux nouvelles
plaintes de deux personnes de deux
jeunes femmes différentes ont été
auraient été déposé alors je vous cache
pas que je j'ai appelé le parquet que
c'est pas très clair cette histoire
parce qu'il parle de deux plaintes qui
ont été déposées à bourambress et en mon
avis alors de ce que je sais euh il
paraît qu'il y a peut-être des erreurs
là-dessus alors il y a peut-être des
erreurs je pense que ça les infosain
mais apparemment g vous avez enqu appar
je vous
apprximation il y a des approximations
c'estàd que je pense que les deux
plaintes à bouren Bress effectivement ce
c'est ce sont les tiennes Julie et selon
mes informations il y aurait juste une
nouvelle plainte il serait il serait
apparemment Gill voilà qui sit pas
recevable apparemment moment oui pour le
moment on a ni l'identité ni la
provenance voilà ce qu'on sait c'est que
c'est la brigade des mineurs qui est
très compétente qui se charge du dossier
tout est regroupé chez eux parce que
Julie donc dans sa plainte euh de de
viol cite un viol alors qu'elle était
mineur donc cette brigade là Cyril qui
est spécialisée va enquêter mais
effectivement il y a encore aujourd'hui
là à cette heurel un aspect flou sur les
autres plaintes c'est vrai oui c'est
assez flou parce qu'en fait il parle de
trois plains dont deux déposés à
bourambbrress donc il y a pas 10000
victimes de Cé qui ont pu déposé à
bourambbrz donc c'est là où c'est flou
et c'est pour ça qu'on demande en tant
que journaliste je pense que je suis pas
la un problème ou des renseignements des
éclaircissement mais moi selon mes infos
il y a quand même une plainte qui a été
posée en plus et selon nos infos je vous
le dis apparemment il y aurait un
problème au niveau de ces plaintes et
qu'elle ne serait pas recevable
apparemment je dis ça avec des ouou faut
prendre le conditionnel mais vous avez
raison démettre ce do conditionnel ouis
c'est ça conditionnel mais voà une
erreur du parquet de bouramb qui devrait
dire qu'il s'est trompé c'est un
exactement appar il y aurait une erreur
du parquet de de de bourambbrress si
c'est le cas c'est grave parce que tous
les médias l'ont annoncé he mais bon je
dis on va on va avoir les infos demain
mais a priori de la petite enquête qu'on
a fait ce serait ça voilà Julie coé
l'avocat de Cé hier parle d'extorsion de
fond et il déclare même qu'ils ont des
preuves de ce qu'ils avance regardent fa
usage parce qu'on a les preuves
matérielles tangibles de la fausseté
d'un certain nombre de choses qui ont
été dites ou produite nous avons annoncé
dès jeudi qu'il y aurait d'autres
plaintes parce que nous savions il y a
avait une montée en puissance avec une
volonté d'obtenir des fonds de la part
de notre client on est donc pas très
surprise très surpris que aujourd'hui
comme par magie une autre plainte sorte
avec on peut le craindre les mêmes
incohérence les mêmes mensonges les
mêmes défauts de preuv que alors je dis
ça semble bien que vous soyez là je vous
sens énervé par ce que vous
voyez je je suis pas vraiment je dirais
pas que je suis énervée je suis plutôt
ça je suis je suis outrée presque c'est
que je trouve que c'est pas c'est pas
logique rien que l'avocat je trouve ce
qu'il dit c'est pas logique quand il
parle d'extorsion de fond est-ce que
vous vous avez réclamé de l'argent à un
moment ou un autre absolument pas Jama
jamais un centime j'ai absolument pas
parler d'argent ne serait-ce qu'avec mon
avocat donc je ils disent apparemment g
qu's auraiit même des preuves oui ils
disent c'est ça qui est troublant Julie
c'est qu'ils disent qu'ils ont des
éléments concrets selon lesquels une
bande organisée plusieurs personnes
aurait non mais je vous pose la question
aurait manipulé vous aussi sans doute
pour obtenir de l'argent en quelque
sorte faire un chantage il prononce pas
les mots mais c'est ça donc est-ce qu'il
y a une quelconque réalité et d'où ça
sort cette cette théorie des avocats de
de Monsieur cohet après moi je je vais
répondre moi ça c'est la justice qui qui
pourra éclaircir l'histoire mais moi les
preuves je les ai pas inventé la justice
elle va elle va le montrer que les
preuves sont pas inventées puisque les
preuves ce sont vraiment les faits et
ils les ont ils ont absolument tout donc
eux ils sauront faire la lumière
là-dessus mais j'ai jamais demander 1
centime et j'aimerais bien voir les
preuves qu'ils ont parce que absolument
j'ai demandé 0 € c'est je suis allée à
mon avocat j'en ai fait d'ailleurs deux
avant de choisir le mien je veux dire
j'en ai pas j'ai pas peur de le dire
j'ai pas parlé d'argent j'ai pas parlé
deargent et c'est pas dans des histoires
comme ça qu'on gagne de l'argent ça faut
faut bien être clair là-dessus aussi
pour pour dire moi je le le samedi où
j'ai été porté plainte c'est je je l'ai
fait je l'ai fait j'étais même pas sûre
d'aller porter plain de ce jour-là c'est
que je je je marchais dans dans dans la
rue et je me suis retrouvé devant la
porte de la gendarmerie et je me suis
dit c'est maintenant ou jamais que tu le
fais c'est-à-dire que je moi je j'y suis
allée j'avais pas d'avocat quand je su
suis partie porter plainte j'y suis
allée j'y suis allé comme ça et j'avais
pas d'avocat bien avant après la plainte
j'en ai trouvé un là maintenant qui qui
a qui qui qui saura défendre l'affaire
mais sinon non donc il y a pas
d'extorsion de fond moi j'y suis allée
comme ça sans même savoir ce qui allait
m'attendre quand est-ce que tu as été en
contact pour la dernière fois avec avec
Sébastien cé cet été cet été on on dit
je te dis tout que tu aurais proposé de
le rejoindre alors ça
c'est c'est ce que gillberdez c'est lui
c'est lui c'est c'est ce que l'entourage
de Sébastien cet m'avait rapporté
effectivementort alors ça je vais il y a
encore les preuve parce que heureusement
que que je garde tout absolument pas
c'est lui qui m'a dit qu'il mixait dans
le 38 d'accordo donc c'est vous qui lu
avz proposé de venir ou c'est lui il il
avait même pas une intention de se
rejoindre il m'a dit je mixe dans le 38
je lui dis ah bon ça et c'est là qui
m'envoie vers un plan d'eau vers la
vallée du plan d'eau je sais pourquoi
non j'y suis pas allé ah d'accord ah
c'est le dernier contact non je n'y suis
pas allée d'accord et la dernière fois
que vous l'avez vu la dernière fois que
je l'ai vu bah c'était en mars en mars
pourquoi 22 c'était pour qu quelle
occasion c'était les faits d'accord les
les faits les deuxièmes faits que vous
relatez h parce que c'est c'est quoi les
deuxièmes faits parce que c'est vrai que
on avait parlé des premiers faits la
dernière fois V c'est quoi les les les
les deuxièmes faits
Julie bah les deuxièmes
faits c'est la même chose que que les
premiers finalement et euh c'est vous
vous voyez où en fait alors on en fait
on se rejoint euh devant les studioos
d'énergie parce que j'étais sur Paris
pour un séminaire du travail on se
rejoint en fait sur vers le ennergie 22
rue boilot et c'est à ce moment-là que
il me dit je je te ramène à ton hôtel
c'est mal c'est mal fréquenter donc je
montre dans sa voiture et finalement je
me retrouve chez
lui d'accord là vous dites quoi vous lui
dites non j'ai envie de rentrer chez moi
ou Mme vous dit bon on va prendre un
verre comment ça se passe bah je non il
propose pas de prendre un verre je lui
dis de simplement que je souhaite sortir
de la voiture il me dit de toute façon
pour remonter non faut un badge et c'est
à ce moment-là que qu'il se repasse les
mêmes faits je vais pas les expliquer
parce que ça
me ça me touche encore beaucoup et je me
sens encore vachement coupable donc je
veux pas trop en parler ça la justice
fera sa lumière aussi s coupable Julie
parce que j'y suis
retourné ça coupable d' d'être revenu le
le voir d'être revenu d'avoir gardé ce
contact de parce qu'on a gardé on a on a
gardé malgré tout
contact malgré tout
euh et c'est et c'est ça que les gens
arrivent pas à comprendre c'est ça
s'appelle l'emprise ça c'est ça
l'emprise c'est ça l'emprise
oui il y a un des avocats vous l'avez
dit vous avez consulté plusieurs avocats
avant de choisir le vôtre il y a un des
avocats qui dit que premièrement vous ne
saviez pas où il habitait au moment où
vous l'avez vu cet avocat et
deuxièmement que vous vous aurez poser à
la question à l'avocat combien est-ce
qu'on peut lui prendre pour cette
affaire est-ce que c'est vrai ou pas
c'est les propos de la personne c'est
pas et Ben qui donne le nom de cet
avocat que j'ai été voir parce que les
avocats ils sont déjà pas médiatiques et
j'en ai j'ai donné absolument le nom à
personne donc si vraiment il l' retrouvé
moi je l'ai eu je vais pas le dire parce
que voilà mais je moi c'est des propos
que j'ai recueilli non mais de l'avocat
oui bah donnez le nom de l'avocat c'est
maître je peux pas le donner parce que
c'est on pas citer nos sources c'est
maître non je vous dirai pas qui mais je
vous dis que j'ai eu un avocat qui m'a
dit
ça c'est une femme c'est une femme ou
c'est un homme c'est un avocat c'est un
homme c'est un avocat tu peux dire c'est
une femme ou un homme c'est un homme et
ben ça prouve que c'est complètement
faux pu des femmes ah oui bah ouais ou
c'est moi j'ai vu un mail où vous l'avez
contacté en disant bonjour je souhaite
oui j'ai pas échangé de mail j'ai appelé
directement j'appelle que les avocats
directement vous avez le mail je fais
isez nous on voir si que j je crois
qu'il m'a envoyé en photo mais je je
l'ai vu de mes propres yeuxs he mais
c'est une avocate que j'ai vu je vois
que des femmes donc jamais vous n'avez
demandé d'argent à J absolument jamais
et ça j'en suis certaine parce que j'en
veux pas vous voulez pas d'argent c'est
pas votre but c'est pas mon but moi mon
but aujourd'hui c'est de pouvoir me
reconstruire et de pouvoir faire
entendre moi ma seule victoire ce serait
de vraiment être considérée comme une
victime mais pouvoir m'en sortir parce
que je vous assure que d'être sous
antidépresseur on ressent plus rien on
vit plus en fait je suis à 300 mg par
jour c'est en fait on est on est comme
ça on est linéaire toute la
médiatisation de cette affaire euh et le
fait que qu' a porté pleinte contre vous
est-ce que c'est c'est vous vous dites
quoi vous dites vous le saviez vous
redoutiez ça vous saviez que ça allait
prendre je le je le redoutais pas parce
que je me je me suis jamais dit bah oui
il va avouer tout de suite je me je me
suis pas dit bah oui il va il va y aller
il va il va s'avouer coupable pas du
tout je savais que j'allais avoir une
plainte de lui je savais qu'il allait
faire des démentis et cetera après moi
je j'ai absolument tout en ma possession
et la justice a aussi les choses donc
après
avoir avoir alors il y a la chaîne qui
dit bien sûr on peut pas montrer le mail
à l'écran ils ont pris pour des é faut
pas dire le nom de l'avocat mais on va
montrer le mail à l'écran on prenne
vraiment pour des con sur la chaîne
c'est bien de le savoir euh c'est
important de savoir qu'on est pris pour
des con dans sa propre chaîne ça fait
toujours plaisir
euh pourquoi il y a y a a il y a des
gens qui qui disent que tu es pas clair
sur ton âge Julie je te pose toutes les
questions comme je t'avais dit qu'est-ce
que tu réponds à ces jours-là parce que
tu dis que la première fois que qu' a eu
voilà
c'est ce drame dans la chambre d'hôtel
tu dis que tu avais 15 ans et il y a pas
mal de gens qui disent que c'est que en
fait tu avais pas 15 ans que tu Moné sur
ton âge et cetera c'est ça g aussi oui
des approximations sur l'âge ça on en a
parlé aussi ensemble est-ce que vous
pouvez remettre effectivement je suis né
en fin de je suis née en fin d'année je
suis née le en septembre donc en fait la
ma première rencontre cétait à 15 ans
quand les fesses se sont passées j'avais
16 ans révolu donc en fait ça c'est
pareil sur la plainte c'est c'est
marquéou c'est marqué et sur les âges
aussi je peux pas mentir son mon ID
justi s prononcée d'une certaine façon
puisque elle a rencontré Koé à 15 ans
mais la le premier acte supposé aurait
eu lieu à 16 ans c'est une Meur DEP plus
de 15 ans c'est ça euh je trouve qu'on
est quand même assez dur avec
Julie qui nous bah non pas pas pas vous
mais je trouve Guillaume voilà je trouve
que malgré tout en fait non mais on
relate vous relatez rien pour l'instant
rien il
aign laissez la parler là ou ouais il y
a une plignante et il y a un en mise en
cause donc on va laisser faire la
justice d'ailleurs Julie l'a dit dès le
début quand elle est venue la première
fois sur le plateau masqué on va laisser
faire la justice mais malgré tout il
faut quand même comprendre que
globalement les femmes qui parlent même
si voilà on ça nous met mal à l'aise bah
globalement les femmes qui parlent et
ben elles disent souvent la vérité voilà
donc il faut quand même le dire je ne
vois pas ce ce que Julie a à gagné
justement qu'est-ce que ça t'a apporté
depuis julie a gagné à part énormément
d' merde en fa qu'est-ce que tu as
t'pporté depuis Julie passe à autre
chose une libération une libération
parce que ça fait 10 ans que je dis rien
ça fait 10 ans que je me suis persuadée
que c'était presque moi la coupable je
me suis mis ma famille presque je dirais
ma famille às disent quoi ils disent
quoi ta famille aujourd'hui il ils se
sentent coupable ah ouais maintenant ils
se sentent coupable parce que ma sœur a
prévenu et malheureusement bah moi je je
l'ai pas écouté j'y suis j'ai continué
elle a alerter mes parents qui m'ont
fait confiance et parce que Cyril
pardonnez-moi mais dans ce genre de
fonctionnement évidemment qu'il y a de
la fascination pour la vedette
évidemment qu'il y a de l'assilération
évidemment qu'il y a de l'emprise
évidemment qu'après on dit ah mais
peut-être qu'il faut faire ça pour pour
être connu pour travailler à la télé ou
pour travailler à la radio donc
peut-être qu'il y a aussi tout ça je ne
sais pas je connais pas le dossier donc
je pense que aussi quand on est regardé
nous par aussi des jeunes qui écrivent à
des gens qui sont connus à des gens qui
qui sont dans le spectacle et tout ça il
faut aussi leur dire ça que voilà elle
peut aussi je ne sais pas si vous vous
dites la vérité où vous montez mais ça
peut aussi participer à un système de de
prédation et tout ça donc il faut quand
même faire très attention aussi et pas
tout de suite la cabler en disant en
gros tu veux quoi la notoriété tu veux
Laune ouais mais
attends un mais pourquoi tu es
retourné été contacté par un avocat qui
a dit que un vous ne connaissiez pas son
adresse et de vous Luiz vous lui auriez
demandé combien vous pouviez récupérer
d'argent à vous de me dire si c'est vrai
ou faux il y a deux version dit
voilà après le téléphone de Julie tu me
dis si je me trompe il a été
perquisitionné donc il y a tout un tas
d'éléments aussi que la police a en sa
possession sur des échanges qui pourrai
être aussi délictueux donc ça c'est la
police de faire de faire son travail moi
je sais que j'ai vu quelques échanges
c'est à la police de voir si ces
échanges à l'âge où tu que tu avais son
tu as eu tu as eu les les les les les
avocats
ont l'air sur de sur de et c'est pour ça
et c'est pour ça même l'avocat hier il a
l'air vraiment et c'est pour ça que
c'est très bien que Julie soit là pour
répondre point par point sur bande
organisée extorsion je ne veux pas
d'argent c'est pour ça que c'est très
clair et qu'elle a tout à fait la
latitude et que Julie a toujours voulu
accepté même pas voulu que les deux
versions puissent être présenter et là
c'est très bien parce que présente que
font et Guillaume mais bien sû
gu il sont obligés ai de demander à Jie
tu Reles rien du tout tu dis un mail que
tu as vaguement reçu d'un
avocatmeoc
trèsux
pas tu vois bien qu' a de verionadoir J
pour don la version des faits c'est très
bien on l'écoute et Julie elle même l'a
dit il a la présontion d'innocence il
faut écouter la version de quoi de ses
avocats c'est pas bien le procè que tu
en train de nous faire géraline ça n'a
rien avoir et moi j'avais une autre
question hier l'avocat de de de ce a
sous-entendu était pas très clair
làdessus d'ailleurs sur les
conversations sur les SMS soit qu'ils
étaient faux soit qu'ils auraient été
modifiés vous vous maintenez que ces
conversations sont réelles qu'elles
n'ont pas été tronquées qu'il y a pas eu
de messagees ont pas elles ont pas été
truquées c'est
c'est ces messages là et de toute façon
quand on fait une comme tu as pu le dire
quand on se fait perquisitionner son
téléphone il retrouve absolument tous
les échanges et tous les messages
supprimés donc même si j'en avais si je
si tout le monde suppose que j'en a
supprimé ils sont retrouvés donc moi
j'ai donné mon téléphone en toute
tranquillité ok mais moi j'ai pu
visionner des choses c'est pas c'est pas
enfin il y a il y a rien de supprimé
effectivement quand on voit une capture
d'écran on peut se dire qu'il y a
quelque chose qui a été supprimé moi
j'ai vu les textos il y a pas il y a pas
de de de choses supprimées vous êtes
plus heureuse oui avant ou maintenant
que vous avez vous avez parlé alors je
dirais pas que je suis plus heureuse
parce que bon maintenant le enfin mon
travail est au courant je veux dire que
ça m'a mis un peu comme dis bien
Géraldine j'ai tout à y perdre moitir
j'ai tout perdre bien sûr j'ai
absolument aucune Rais votre entourage
votre entourage et même les vos
collègues il disent quoi ils vous
soutiennent ils disent quoi mes
collègues me soutiennent mon entourage
aussi après après c'est c'est quand même
très difficile parce que dans le milieu
médical on on voit beaucoup de monde
donc c'est vrai que aujourd'hui vous
avez montré votre visage à énormément de
monde c'est la prière fois que je
parce que il circulait sur les réseaux
sociaux mais jamais voilà aussi voilà
aussi exposé euh demain donc il y a
encore desut des gens qui vont vous en
reparler euh vous l'avez fait aussi
pourquoi pour parce que vous pour
montrer que la parole en fait on doit on
doit plus avoir peur et que c'est
important de que c'est important de
parler alors je dis pas d'aller parler
dans les médias si ces personneslà ne
veulent pas le faire elles peulvent le
faire directement en gendarmerie ou à la
police à le parquet elles peuvent se
rendre en gendarmerie mais il faut
montrer que en fait toutes ces
accusations là c'est c'est enfin pour
moi c'est pour faire peur et j'ai j'ai
plus peur et je ne veux plus avoir peur
j'ai eu assez peur je je veux dire avant
même que que ce soit révélé sur Twitter
en mon nom propre j'avais j'étais passé
par un compte un compte anonyme j'ai
reçu quand même un appel d'une fausse
avocate et ça je pense que personne
enfin c'est bizarre personne n' parle
mais j'ai reçu un appel d'une fausse
avocate vous dit sur Twitter ou ou VO
mais bon mais personne ne se mais
personne ne revient là-dessus mais j'ai
été intimidée d'accord j'ai été
intimidée et il faut plus en fait avoir
peur j'ai eu peur non parce que mais
j'ai mais j'ai eu très peur au départ je
me suis dit jamais je pourrais aller
porter plainte je me suis dit mais c'est
pas possible je je j'ai trop peur ils
vont venir chez moi j'ai commencé à
flipper et finalement je me suis dit
mais pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi avoir
peur tu vas te rendre en gendarmerie et
justement c'est eux qui vont qui vont
faire la lumière sur cette histoire et
je leur fais entièrement confiance
puisque je leur ai donné mon téléphone
et qu'ils l'ont extrait donc pour moi il
y a
absolument oui puis elle merci Julie
merci désolé 21h18 merci Julie d'avoir
été avec nous merci Miriam de votre
témoignage tout de suite c'est monjille
sur C8
[Applaudissements]
merci ce matin chapoline de Malerbe la
mère de roman surrizer est revenu sur le
meurtre de Thomas qui secoue la région
et le pays depuis plus d'une semaine
elle a déclaré que le nom des agresseurs
avait été donné bien trop tard selon
elle elle n'est pas la seule à dénoncer
une omerta car les prénoms des
agresseurs seraient devenu un enjeu
politique est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec elle est-ce qu'il fallait donner
très vite le nom des essur euh voilà oui
ou
non regardez merci
Bruno moi je je pense que de de ne pas
avoir communiqué sur les prénoms
plusutôt euh c'était ah je trouve que
c'était indécent ça je je le dis parce
que par respect pour les familles je ne
vois pas pourquoi lorsqu'il s'agit d'un
autre drame et bien on va communiquer
nom prénom tout de suite et là qui il a
été nécessaire
enfin chacun attendait et finalement les
noms circulaient sur les réseaux sociaux
avant qu'il ne soit confirmé par les
autorités quelle guignole euh non je
parlais d'un déchron euh merci Stanislas
Rigo d'être avec nous porte-parole de
reconquête euh pour vous il fallait
donner les noms bien entendu ou pas
ouais bien sûr et d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant que ce soit la mère de roman
stzer qui en parle ce matin chez votre
conur appolline de malerde c'est
absolument indécant d'avoir caché aussi
longtemps les noms d'autant que on a
appris dans le Figaro cette semaine que
Géral confie les noms à un ministre et
en lui disant si ça se sait ça peut
embraser le pays ça peut énerver le pays
de savoir les nom aê raison le ministre
de l'intérieur ou à la fin des fin il a
le pou du pays quand même le ministre de
l'Intérieur en fait il sait que ça va
attendre les gens mais plus il les
cachent plus il les dissimuent plus les
gens demandent plus les gens demandent
et puis quand ça arrive ça énerve encore
plus les gens et donc je crois que la
meilleure des choses dans ce genre de
situation c'est d'être transparent
c'estêtre transparent sur les profils
c'est transparent sur les nom sur les
cas judiciire parce que les personnes
qui ont causé le drame de de crpol qui a
conduit à la mort de Thomas ce jeune ran
de 16 ans ils sont en plus connu des
services de police donc je crois qu'on a
le droit nous Français de savoir qui
sont les gens qui sèment la terreur dans
notre pays ah oui mais derrière quand le
le ministre de l'Intérieur dit que ça va
il vair un embrasement on peut on peut
aussi le croire il y en a beaucoup ici
qui sont pour qui sont d'accord avec la
merre de morsan surizer notamment
Jacques cardose oui moi je crois que ça
sert à rien de de vouloir dissimuler la
la vérité et je suis pour que ce soit le
cas quel que soit le fait divers et de
façon à éviter des interprétations et je
trouve que le fait de le dissimuler fait
naître aussi une forme de peut-être de
de fantasme ou en tous les cas nous
amène à amène une partie du pays à se
demander pourquoi le ministère de
l'Intérieur ne veut pas donner et livrer
les les noms des des des des les prénoms
qu'on s'appelle Paul ou qu'on s'appelle
Mohamed je pense parce que quel que soit
le le le cas et quel que soit le fait
divers quel que soit ce qui s'est passé
à chaque fois pour moi c'est c'est c'est
la règle devrait être la même et ça
éviterait les fantam oui parce que c'est
contreproductif parce que paradoxalement
c'est là où on va encore plus
stigmatiser parce que comme on imagine
et que c'est ça nourrit tous les
fantasmes en disant on nous cache des
choses et cetera ben quand le quand
quand les noms émergent on nous dit bah
Vous vous avez vu on a voulu nous cacher
des choses alors que moi je pense
qu'effectivement la règle doit être la
même pour tous si on est on donne pour
tout le monde ou on donne pour personne
mais voilà euh à partir du moment où on
commence à donner pour les uns on donne
pour les autres euh et et euh et et je
et je pense que à l'inverse de ce qui a
voulu êté fait voulu être fait c'est
c'est-à-dire calmer le pays bah ça a
fracturé encore plus le pays Danny oui
c'est ce qui est scandaleux c'est qu'en
plus ils se sont empressés au début de
nous dire que c'était des Français euh
et c'est vrai mais ensuite ils ont caché
les noms quand ils sont aperçus qu'en
fait les noms n'étaient pas qu'ance
française donc c'est un véritable
mensonge on nous prend vraiment je suis
désolé mais pour des cons et quand
Darman a parlé des Kevin et Matthéo pour
les émeutes là les prénom cétait
important il fallait les très intéress
je suis entièement d'accord avec Daniel
Mor c'estàd ce qui est intéressant c'est
que j'ai l'occasion de débattre
notamment sur une autre chaîne de
télévision où ça comment tu sur quelle
chaîne je DIRIS pas le nom ça va énerver
tout le monde sur le plateau c'était sur
BFM ça va et donc j'étais sur BFM et
quand je dis que parce que ça ça se
murmurait parce que tout le monde avait
vu les images il y a des vidéos qui ont
circuler sur les réseaux sociaux du
début de l'agression et quand on voit le
début les ces vidéos qui traînent et CEA
on comprend le genre de prof c'est des
gens issus de population immigré
magrébine sauf que ce qui est scandaleux
c'est que quand on le disait il nous
tapait arrêé de dire n'importe quoi
c'est pas vrai vous êtes scandaleux et
donc encore une fois il y a eu une
complicité Politi médiatique pour que
les Français ne sachent pas ce qui s'est
réement passéors Gill Verdez je reprends
Daniel sur un point ahurissant qui est
passé comme ça elle a dit on s'est
aperçu que c'était pas des noms à
consenance française ça veut dire que
Gill c'est français et Souleiman c'est
pas consonance française non mais c'est
incroyable de dire ça mais c'est de la
folie de dire ça
ou B nom français des mauais nom
français plus l'origine de certains
pr sont tous français vous êes
mal
France
estan c'est pas le dire
qu' et alors après pour les prénoms moi
je suis totalement contre le fait qu'on
donne ses prénoms d'abord la justice
très souvent ne les donne pas il y a pas
de règles il y a pas de loi le procureur
fait ce qu'il veut souvent en France ne
les donne pas et il faut pas être dupe
si on les donne aujourd'hui pourquoi
c'est pour que des monsieurs des gens
comme vous monsieur Rigo puissiez
récupérer politiquement parce qu'on va
être très clair Cyril ah c'est Rachid
tiens ça sonne arabe tiens peut-être
qu'il est musulman venu de l'immigration
et Bou on désingle l'immigration et
c'est de la faute de l'immigration le
drame incroyable de la mort de Thomas
bouleversant vous allez dire maintenant
c'est de la faute des immigrés et ça ça
c'est de la récupération politique hon
je cro je crois justement le vrai sujet
làdessus c'est pas la récupération ça
c'est un argument bidon parce queit en
prétextant que ce que nous fais ce que
nous faisons c'est la récupération on
occulte le débat de fond le débat de
fond c'est dans ce pays oui il y a un
lien entre l'insécurité et l'immigration
ça c'est factuel c'est pas moi qui le
dit c'est Monsieur Darmanin qui lui-même
cachait les noms je vous donne quelques
chiffres en vraque mais qui vont vous
parler et qui sont pas de moi qui sont
de Monsieur Darmanin 55 % de la
délinquence à Marseille sont le fait de
personnes étrangères 55 %. ça veut dire
quoi étrangère ah bah des personnes qui
sont pas de papier ce sont des étrangers
dans les transports au commun c'est 90 %
des vols commis par les étrangers là
c'est des Français oui mais sauf que il
y a un lien entre immigration et
délincance premier élément deuxième
élément pas inintéressant non plus on
sait très bien que ces vagues
d'immigration peuvent causer ce genre de
dégâts ça peut être des
dégâtsimmigration oui à 500000 entré
parents vous appelez ça comment vous ah
c'est la su
m s000 par ouimion
je sais pas attention quand même au
raccourci entre l'immigration et une
automaticité
avec les choses comme ça je pense pas
vousz fa li les le lien il est pas
établi comme ça c'est pas un discours
que vous pouvez reprendre comme ça
tranquillement sur un plateau télév plus
comp mon il fait de chos il parle
d'ensuvagement terme que je reprends
volontiers et il donne ses chiffres sans
faire un lien avec
l'imigration dans laéé est d'accord mais
monsieur de fait de fait fait le lien
puis tu don ces chiffres là encore une
fois c'est factuel c'est que tous les
immigrés ne sont pas délinquentss mais
une grande part de la délinquence en
France de la criminalité est le fruit de
personnes étrangères tout comme dans nos
prisons il y a 25 % de
personnesliours c'est pas automatique
mais en tout cas c'estu comm comm les
antibiotiques
ouais on vit quand même dans un monde un
peu particulier quand même parce que on
veut maintenant on veut dénoncer les euh
ces gens pitoyables qui ont qui ont
commis une horreur absolue que tout le
monde bien évidemment condamne euh dans
le monde dans lequel on vit aussi
actuellement avec Internet ben
finidalement visiblement on n' pas
besoin de dénoncer parce que on ils se
font dénoncer on connaît la photo on
connaît l'adresse on con et ce qui amène
à dénoncer bah ça va aller voir les
parents ça va voir des meurtres et
encore des bagarres ça va aller faire
des des rencontres qui a eu lorsqu'il y
a eu là avec la descente de l'extrême
droite bon je vous dis moi
personnellement aujourd'hui je suis
assez perd vraiment parce que on parle
d'émigration on parle de dire bah lui il
est n en France ben non parce qu'il
s'appelle Rachid ou il s'appelle mundir
bah il est pas français franchement ça
ça me fait vraiment chier je vous le dis
vraiment ça me fait vraiment chier c'est
très c'est très grave ce qui s'est passé
moi je je sais pas quoi vous dire en
fait pour toi il fallait donner les noms
ou pas non faut pas donner nom parce
qu'il y a une justice et puis quoi qu'il
arrive les noms all les sortir donc quoi
qu'il arrive pourquoi donner les noms
donc donne les noms l'adresse
l'âge tu c'est le contraire en fait mon
dire tu crois pas que le fait que le
gouvernement ou le ministère de
l'Intérieur ENF je sais pas exact ement
comment les choses se sont faites ou le
procureur de la République d'ailleurs
peut-être le fait que on ne divulgue pas
les noms fait que dans les jours qui ont
suivi c'est d'ailleurs ce qui s'est
passé ce weekend finalement bah comme ça
a été expliqué ça circulait sous le
manteau et puis il y a eu cette idée
selon laquelle ah le gouvernement veut
cacher parce que majoritairement ce sont
des noms à consonance maghrébine et donc
du coup ça fait naître quelque chose à
mon avis qui qui qui vient crisper
encore un peu plus le débat tu vois ce
que je veux dire et donc je me dis moi
mais pourquoi ne pas donner ces
informations là de façon très
automatique dès le départ pour éviter
que depuis quand en France on dénonce
enfin on pas déoncer mais on doit dire
les noms aujourd'hui moi c'est la
première fois j'ai 50 Bala c'est la
première fois que pas dénoncer justement
c'est de dire le nom donc le nom prénom
et de dire que le mec est un
Arab cont banaliser il faut dire les
choses met no
alors merci Benjamin d'être avec nous
merci beaucoup cette histoire c'est une
des histoires les plus fortes euh voilà
qu'on est connu sur touche pas mon poste
il est 20h57 on est en direct c'est avec
force et courage que vous acceptez de
témoigner ce soir en direct à la
télévision il vous a arrivriver une des
pires choses qui puissent arriver au
cours d'une vie perdre un enfant et la
la manière dont vous avez perdu votre
fille est dramatique euh quel âge avait
votre fille 3 ans c'est ça ouais elle
avait 3 ans ouais H 3 ans elle
s'appelait comment Estelle Estelle tout
allait bien dans votre vie tout allait
bien euh avec la maman depuis combien de
temps ça faisait 12 ans qu'on était
ensemble le bonheur une rencontre
standard le
bonheur on a profité de la vie enfin une
vie normale quoi avec Sandra avec Sandra
avec Sandra Lodi ça étiez vous étiez
vous étiez très amoureux très lié très
enfin une belle une belle famille j'ai
rencontré une femme douce sensible qui
m'a charmé je suis tombé amoureux d'elle
on a pris le temps de vous êtes connu
comment on s'est connu via des amis qui
nous ont lors d' soir qui nous ont
présenté on a échangé des mots s'est
bien passé on a bien rigolé on s'est
revu et on est sorti ensemble d'une
manière classique quoi bien sûr et après
donc là vous êtes resté 12 ans ensemble
exactement ouais vous étiez marié non
non on est en union libre en couple
d'accord
euh vous avez donc
Estelle ça se passe bien au moment de la
naissance d''estelle ouais cétait un
choix commun de fonder une famille voir
une fille la naissance d'Estelle on est
ravi c'est le moment de bonheur quand on
on démarre la vie de famille tout se
passe bien on s'occupe chacun tous les
deux d' Stell euh et et on commence à
construire une vie standard quoi vous
étiez heureux on était heureux ouais h
rrouvz votre petite fille tous les tous
les soirs faites quoi dans la vie je
suis menusé ouais d'accord
euh mais il y a des tensions qui ont
fait que vous souétiez vous souitiez
mettre fin à la relation si c'est pas
trop indiscret pourquoi qu'est-ce qui se
passait euh à la naissance de notre
fille Sandra c'est elle s'est centrée
sur elle c'est devenu V qu'elle était
jalouse aussi elle était jalouse
possessive même vis-à-vis de moi c'est
ce que j'ai expliqué voilà dès que je
parlais à une femme ou que j'avais une
amie trop proche que je l'appelais trop
souvent elle était jalouse faisa des
remontrances et tout ce que je disais ça
va un petit côté flatteur aussi d'avoir
une femme qui tient à soi je le voyais
pas d'une manière extrême et non plus
comme un défaut trop
important mais ce côté possessif il
s'est accentué au fil du temps avec
notre fille c'est devenu son seul centre
d'intérêt moi-même j'avais plus de place
j'ai perdu ma place de père et Sandra
était exclusivement centré sur elle
votre place de père et votre place aussi
de j'ai perdu ma place de de conjoint
dans un premier temps VO c'est ça
d'abord elle voulait s'occuper
exclusivement de votre fille et elle
vous excluit de l'éducation c'est ça
exactement ouais alors pourquoi elle
voulait pas vous occuper elle disait
c'est ça y est c'était son son son alors
au début je m'en occupais les 6 premiers
mois je' je m'en suis occupé après j'ai
repris le boulot je me suis centré sur
mon boulot d'un côté j'étais content
qu'elle s'en occupe qu'elle donne les
biberons et et Sandra a arrêté de
travailler pour s'occuper de notre fille
euh et du coup je m'en suis occupé de
moins en moins euh et j jusqu'à plus
m'en occuper du tout dès que je voulais
lui donner un biberon faire une couche
je le faisais pas bien je faisais pas
comme il faut euh elle elle m'a
complètement évincé de mon rôle de père
au fil du temps quoi alors
euh vous vous séparez h c'est vous qui
décidez de vous séparer vous lui dites
ouais c'est elle avait quel âge Estelle
quand vous êtes séparé quand on s'est
séparé elle avait 3 ans 3 ans donc c'est
is euh vous séparez vous lui dites quoi
vous lui dites il faut qu'on on se
sépare euh quand en fait j'avais plus
mon rôle de conjoint et quand je lui je
me suis aperçu que mon rôle de père il
s'effritait euh je lu dit que cétait
plus possible quoi vous préfériez en
fait avoir une garde partagée comme ça
quand vous avez la f vous vous en
occupez c'était plus c'était plus
c'était mieux d'avoir limite votre fille
de jours par semaine plutôt que tous les
jours et de laavir pas de pas laavir du
tout en fait c'est ça ouais c'est ça
ouais je
euh je lui demandé la la la garde
alternée et pour elle c'était
inacceptable euh elle a jamais envisagé
de de de se séparer de sa fille donc
donc comment que vous faisiez pour voir
votre fille comment vous faisiez comment
pour voir votre fille
je la voyais mais je pouvais je pouvais
pas pass non j'avais plus de moments
seul avec elle en fait comme elle
travaillait plus dès que moi j'étais à
la maison elle était là et pour moi
voilà dès qu'on allait se promener
Sandra était toujours là et c'est au fil
du temps et c'est que tard où où moi je
je lui ai exprimé et je me suis entre
guillemets révolté contre elle tard en
lui disant mais il faut aussi que moi
j'ai des moments seul avec elle que je
puisse aller me promener seul avec elle
et quand je disais ça si si je voulais
faire une action avec qu'elle il fallait
qu'on en arrive à la dispute alors vous
faisz chambre à pas hein ouais c'est ça
h euh
et c'est le 12 novembre
2020 chez vous au nord de Lyon que le
pire arrive incroyable puis que on vous
a raconté le début de l'histoire donc un
couple tout à fait normal qui se
rencontre ils ont une petite fille
qu'ils aiment passionnément ils ont une
ça se passe très bien et puis bon après
voilà il y a des problèmes dans le
couple ça peut arriver après l'année
d'un enfant tout ça c'est assez
classique enfin ça arrive quoi et voilà
vous faites chambre part peut-être
qu'après on s'est dit parfois il y a des
couples qui qui reprennent et qui
repartent mieux qu'avant mais vous le 12
novembre 2020 vous entendez votre fille
pleurer en pleine nuit parce que vous
faites chambre à part vous entendrez
votre fille
pleurer
vraiment et elle elle hurle non elle
pleure il arrivait qu'elle pleure la
nuit parce que je pense que c'est les
toutes les tensions qu'on a avait on
s'était promis on essayait de plus
disputer devant elle enfin je pense que
c'est des disputes qui troublaient ces
nuits et il arrivait souvent qu'elle
pleure la nuit cette nuit-là je l'ai
entendu et comme si sa mère qui s'en
occupait et et je suis pas monté la voir
je me suis dit elle va s'en occuper pas
allé parce que vous êtes dit sa maman va
s'en occuper ouais et je me suis
rendormi comme toutes les nuits et là
elle pleurez plus vous n'entendez plus
rien sinement ouais le lendemain matin
euh vous préparez pour aller au travail
VZ voir votre fille et là c'est
l'horreur le matin je me réveille comme
d'habitude je monte les marches
j'entends murmurer dans la chambre
d'Estelle j'entends que mon ex-conjointe
qui parle et je me dis comment ça se
fait qu'elle parle toute
seule donc je décide de monter
voir et là j'entre dans la chambre de ma
fille et je découvre ma fille sur son
lit avec mon ex conjoint de pencher sur
elle et là
et je je vois les les je vois le le sang
tous les impacts votre femme tue votre
fille Estelle âgé de 3 ans de plus de
354 coups de
couteau avec un ciseau céit un ciseau
oui donc près de 50 au niveau de la
nuque ouais ça s'est passé donc dans la
nuit
h j'imagine quand vous voyez quand vous
revoyez la scène c'est c'est je vous
vois c'est c'est c'est c'est
insoutenable c'est les images que j'ai
vu je j'ai été transperscé de peur
j'étais engourdi j'ai j'ai pas tout de
suite compris ce qui s'est passé ah euh
vous voyez votre F en son j'ai vu tous
ces impacts j'ai vu une tache de sang
derrière sa tête
j'ai je comprenais pas je tremblais
et glacer le sang je sais exactement ce
que c'est physiquement j'ai ressenti
aujourd'hui mais oui c'est ça c'est
comment on doit se sentir on doit plus
tenir sur sur ces sur ses jambes et h
vous faites quoi à ce moment-là parce
que on a on se dit vous trouvez votre
femme euh elle elle elle l'aurait tué
dans dans dans la nuit he quand vous
l'avez entendu pleurer c'est ça ouais et
donc là c'est le matin elle est toujours
penchée sur elle alors que votre fille
est en 100 354 coup de
ciseau vous faites quoi vous dites quoi
je je dis qu'est-ce qui se passe
euh je comprenais pas et là elle m'a pas
répondu enfin elle s'est tourné vers moi
elle m'a dit c'est toi qui a fait ça tu
as voulu nous séparer
ouais qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ça
j'ai rien répondu j'avais mon téléphone
dans les mains je voulais appeler les
pompiers et je tremblais tellement que
j'y suis pas arrivé donc j'ai V sentez
de récupérer votre fille de voirou là je
me suis dit il faut que je la sauve
j'avais qu'une qu'une idée en tête
c'était de la sauver et j'ai pas vu la
transition entre le moment où il était
allongé dans son lit et au moment où
j'ai baissé la tête pour taper sur mon
téléphone je j'ai relevé les yeux elle
l'avait serré contre elle comme ça et je
me suis dit il faut que que je la sauve
faut que je la récupère pour appeler les
pompiers et la sauver quoi j'essaie de
récupérer Stell je commence à à tirer
mais elle a tellement d'impact je me dis
que si je tire trop fort je vais je vais
euh vous allez avoir un je vais l'abîmer
ça du coup je commence à je commence à
lui taper sur la tête je me dis il faut
que je laassomme il faut qu'elle lâche
quoi donc je commence à lui mettre des
coups de POS dans la tête euh et
j'arrive pas à laassommer elle elle
tient elle avec son bras tout j'arrive à
lui faire lâcher son bras son bras
repasse devant moi je la mors je casse
son bras avec mes dents et je prends un
puit avec mon pied sur sa tête et là je
tire fort Estelle et et je cours jusqu'à
chez mes voisins c'est ça vous vous
enfermez chez votre voisin vous avez
votre fille dans les bras et secours
arrive que se passe-t-il les secours
arrivent enfin avant ça il y a eu des
trucs mais enfin je suis pas arrivé à
faire le massage cardiaque c'est Nico
qui l'a fait c'était très compliqué et
tout votre voisin mon voisin ouais et du
coup les secours arrivent il y a le SAMU
mais à ce momentl je reprends espoir je
me dis il faut qu'il la saauve et tout
et quand il branche le le monitoring ou
le et là je reprends espoir et tout
parce que j'ai j'ai l'impression qu'il y
a comme son cœur qui bat et malgré les
doutes et la vision d'horreur et tout je
me dis [__] elle viit encore et tout
faut qu'il la sauve quoi
et et malgré tout ça voilà un moment il
s'arrête et il m'annonce que c'est
terminé quoi
votre maison est placée ensuite sous cé
vous vous retrouvez à l'hôpital nu c'est
ça euh je ouais donc à la suite à la
suite du du déessès moi je suis emmené
je suis emmené dans les camions de
pompiers je suis à l'hôpital les
gendarmes j'étais en cçon et en T-shirt
je me levais il récupère mon t-shirt mon
calçon il le metettent dans des pièces à
conviction donc je me retrouve nu en
tenue en chambre d'hôpital quoi en
tunique d'hôpital et euh et par la suite
donc j'ai j'ai j'avais plus de téléphone
euh plus de portefeuille plus de voiture
plus de maison je me suis retrouvé au
sens propre à poil alors ensuite euh
votre votre excompagne Sandra a avoué
son meurtre h à 6h45 elle avait créé un
SMS à sa mère elle lui avait dit J'ai
tué ma fille il a voulu la garde totale
je ne peux vivre sans elle
euh comment elle a voué son meurtre à
part par ce ce sms elle a al elle av
fait ce SMS dans un premier temps
ensuite quand je suis arrivé dans la
chambre la phrase qu'elle m'a dit tu as
voulu nous séparer c'est toi qui a fait
ça tu as voulu nous séparer les pompiers
et les gendarmes sont
arrivés sa déclaration ça été de
dire j'ai réfléchi toute la nuit il
voulait me l'enlever j'étais obligé de
le
faire est-ce que lui avait déjà lever la
main dessus ça a toujours été une femme
douce sensible attentionnée il y a aucun
signe
elle l'a jamais frappé elle a jamais eu
un mot difficile pour elle elle était
très attentionnée et elle laissait
personne s'en occuper à part elle parce
qu'elle voulait que tout soit bien fait
tout bien cadré quoi il y avait que sa
mère moi-même j'ai été exclu au fil du
temps il avait plus que sa mère qui
avait le droit de s'en occuper quoi
alors maintenant on va passer au encore
un
step puisque le le 9 novembre dernier le
procès a eu lieu votre votre ancienne
compagne a été déclarée irresponsable
pénalement elle sera donc pas jugée et
n'ira pas en
prison quand une irresponsabilité est
prononcée c'est qu'il y a eu au
préalable une contreexertise avec deux
autres experts euh et donc elle a été
considéré comme entre guillemets folle
donc pas de
procès après avoir mis 354 coups de
ciseau à votre fille à sa fille et
aujourd'hui donc pas de procès comment
comment vous avez accueilli cette cette
décision j'avais toujours gardé espoir
que la justice fasse son travail de
parler les expertises psychiatriques et
tout c'est pour ça que moi j'ai jamais
voulu médiatiser cette histoire mais
quand quand il a été établi qu'elle
allait être irresponsable je suis dit je
peux pas accepter ça et je suis obligé
de dénoncer cette injustice et et j'ai
j'ai accueilli jusque à la chambre
d'instruction il y a eu la chambre
d'instruction j'ai toujours gardé soir
j'ai eu le sentiment que le jury et
l'avocat général avait une lecture
objective parce qu'ils ont approuvé
qu'elle mentait sur ses voix ils ont
approuvé qu'elle avait une mémoire
parcellaire pour s'arranger et se
déculpabiliser
elle met tout elle rejette toute la
culpabilité sur moi-même et et du coup
jusque à la chambre d'instruction j'ai
toujours gé espoir je me suis dit ils
vont prendre la la bonne décision et
c'est le 16 novembre qu'ils ont annoncé
qu'elle était irresponsable et et j
jusqu'à ce jour-là je gardais espoir
mais quand ils ont annoncé ça j'ai été
révolté euh je veux dire vis-à-vis de ma
fille c'est c'est inaudible et c'est un
manque de respect euh incroyable
aujourd'hui 3 semaines après le procès
et et 3 ans après le drame votre
ex-compagne est à l'hôpital euh
elle y sera combien de temps selon vous
aucune idée euh voilà elle est plus
entre les mains de la justice moi-même
je sais pas où elle est aujourd'hui euh
passer dans quel hôpital je ne sais pas
je sais pas on me tiendra pas informé de
quand est-ce qu'elle sortira elle
sortira quand les experts
psychiatres jugeront qu'elle est lucide
et non dangereuse pour la société elle
peut sortir dans 2 ans comme dans 3 ans
5 ans bien s elle va sortir elle va
sortir oui elle va sortir
les c'est je vous dis moi je suis
révolté par votre histoire aujourd'hui
et ce qu'on envie de savoir les
téléspectateurs c'est comment Benjamin
on reprend une vie normale
après un tel drame là je crois que c'est
le pire la pire chose qui puisse arriver
euh c'est déjà la justice est très lente
très longue et jusqu'à cette procédure
je voilà mon combat c'était de rendre
justice à ma fille aujourd'hui c'est
terminé je me sens un peu désarmé
désappointé j'ai j'ai l'impression de
devoir redémarrer à zéro maintenant je
je je réamorce travailler ou pas non je
travaille toujours pas ouais vous
arrivez pas je j'arrive pas à travailler
je me suis aussi fracturé la jambe ça a
été très long on m'a opéré il y a 4 mois
vivre une vie normale impossible
euh une vie
normale pour l'instant non parce que
j'arrive pas à reprendre le travail
c'est trop compliqué je suis tout toute
cette histoire tout tout ce tout ce
bruit que ça fait ça ça me ça m'épuise
quoi vous réhabiter dans votre maison ou
pas ouais j'habite dans ma maison la
maison où il y a eu le drame la maison
où il y a eu le drame ouais h ouais j'ai
pu réintégrer ma maison à la suite des
cambriolages de l'inondation il y a eu 8
mois de travaux qui ont été effectués
j'ai fait des combats contre les
assurances euh qui m'ont exclu mon
assurance habitation m'a exclu parce
queils m'ont expliqué qu'il y avait trop
de de sinistres sur ma maison euh donc
j'ai fait des combats avec les avocats
euh et une fois qu'elle a été rénovée
euh j'ai pu réintégrer ma maison ça
aussi on peut je voulais le le pointer
du doigt c'est c'est qu'on m'a rendu la
maison en l'état on est retourné avec
les gendarmes euh j'y suis allé avec un
huissier les gendarmes m'ont rendu les
clés devant ma porte d'entrée et et ils
sont partis et j'ai récupéré une maison
cambriolée gaziel extincteur inondé avec
la scène de crime c'est mon frère et mon
cousin qui ont nettoyé la scène de crime
et c'est moi-même euh dans un deuxème
enfin plus tard qui repeint le mur de la
chambre de ma fille parce que
je je ça me tenait à cœur de le faire
c'est c'est une manière de me
reconstruire donc je réintégré cette
maison parce que pour moi c'est la
maison euh où ma fille a grandi où on a
partagé tous ces moments de bonheur
c'est c'est mon pilier psychologique euh
j'ai mes nuits sont très compliquées
euh je dors très mal mais ça me tient à
cœur d'être là-bas à partir du moment de
toute façon où je suis seul que je dorme
chez moi ou ailleurs je mes nuit c'est
un cauchemar merci d'avoir été avec nous
et on pense on se dit on se met tous à
votre place on se dit que c'est un
véritable cauchemar merci en tout cas
pour votre témoignage très très fort et
on est on espère que vous allez pouvoir
vivre une vie normale maisme si on se
doute bien que c'est extrêmement
compliqué après ce que vous avez vécu en
tout cas merci n les- je peux ajouter
que je je suis euh voilà je on a une
petite
je voulais aussi remercier Christian
stavski et l'association Delphine
Cendrine
form pour essayer de faire avancer les
choses sur Modifier la loi de l'article
1221 c'est ça donc je comptais sur vous
Cyril pour essayer de de monter la
pétition de ouais de faire monter la
pétition une pétition ah je pensais que
c terminé on va en parler on va en
parler demain on va en parler demain si
on va parler tous les jours pour faire
monter cette pétition parce que je suis
complètement d'accord avec vous puisque
n'est pas palement responsable la
personne qui a été qui était atteinte au
moment des fait d'un trouble psychique
ou neuropsychique ayant aboli son disc
le contrôle de ses actes et ça il a
raison ça il faut que ça bouge parce que
c'est inadmissible donc on va faire on
en parlera tous les jours pendant un peu
de temps merci mer vous merci beaucoup
merci à
tousci